>>> TIS'
MONT ST DANGEROUS BOUT SEXUAORIR
IT'S LED TO BOOK  AUTHORS SUCH
MORRISONMA ATWOOD AN
JULU
>> THE STATE OFLORTO STAND EDUCN
NOINDOCTTI
>> THE LIO AND
THE DSULTT-WING
>> THE DEMOC BELIEVE THAT
NOOLITICS.OULDN'T VEAY IN  PS FE
>>IJ
S AR TDING FOR
LIBEAND PROGRESSIV DS'S LAALED
ONE OF T PNTED TO
D THAT WASUPPOSED TO
WHICH HAS ADVOCATED TH LIBER,
CLSRGHTS ICTS
ACROSS AMERICA.
ELLIE REED HAS MORE ON WHO THEY
CHILDREN TO ADULT NC
IDENTITY, WE ARE
AS CARRY A LOAD THAT
IS MUCH TOO HEAVY FOR THEM.
>> MHT I INSTEF
ANWE CURSIVE.APPROPRIATE, AND I
SCHOS.S FOR LI A PARENT
ACTIVIST GROUP.
IT BEGAN IN FLORIDA IN1
CHOOLS BEING
CLOSED FOR AND MASK
MANDATES.
THE GROUP BECAME A FREQUENT ANID
>> THIBO
250 IBERTY  GROUP
SAYS, AND IT HAS GD
CONSERVATIVEIED MO
AGAIPPOSED INDOCTRINATION  RACE
SEXUALITY.
DOT O LEARN  I
THISREE S
NT.RIGHT. SO BOOKS SHLD
THAT CATEGORY AS WELL.
>> Reporter: WED TO HAT'DRE
MOMS ON A DEEPER L THAL DEOS.T
CONSERVATIVES WON RIL PASO CODO
WATCH A MEETING WHERE THEY G LEU
TALKED AUT THE
BO ITHEYL  GUYIN?T MOMS FORTY H
CLAIMING SCHOOS
CONTAIN BOOKS TH FOREIGT.R TRYIS
REMOVED.
ACCORDING TO THE SME COURT'S
DEFINITION OF RE
PORN.
>> I'VE READEFUR
GROUP.
HIS IS KIND OF LIKE MORAL NIT PE
AN IRRATIONAL FEAR O'S GOING . .
WE'RE NOT LOOKING  BBOOKS.
WE JUST NEO A
>> ONE OF THE TSATTHEIR KIDS AR.
5.  READ ATN HIGHHOUSE
>> NO.
AGAIN, AGE APPROPRIATE.
>>O NOT BE APPROPRIATE
FOR A 6-YEAR-OLD IATE
FO15-YEAR-OLD.
>> IS SOE ASSIGNING A FIRST
GRADER TSE 5?
>> NO.
BUT IT'S THE RIGHTF E TO KNOW T
HAVE ACCESS TO AT HOME OF THE
OWON
IN MARCHLORADO'S DTRT 11
HOOL BOARD CONSIDERED A
O PREVENTEACHE THEIR PUNROTESTS.
E GROOMING KIDS WITH
PRONOUNCES IN D-11HE SCHOOL BOA
WHY ING D THEI PROPOSAL.
INDOCTRINATION?
>> IF YOK O 7 AND 8 WHATOUR
PRONON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT
IS.N AT, YOU'RE
PLANTING THEEED IN TINDS
THATHEE SHOULDDENTIFY  ANOTHERR
INR IS
HIP OR
HEY, MY TEACHER IS ASKING ME.
SO MAYBE THIS IS WHAT  DO.
I DIDN'T L I WAS WAY ABOUT MY TE
M MY HEALTH
TEACHER.
IT WAS FROM WANGVERAD PI
YEAH.
BUT AND I THINK THATOW
OF U WE WANTED TO HE THEE LIBER
MEG, PASSE TNOTE CGROUP.
DAY WWITH T
FEELING PEER PRE BE GAY ?
>>or AN A
RI.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING AROUNYING
OKAY,  WHINK ABOUT
IT.
GENDER E YOU?
>> THEY SAITS T.ERNABE MY PERSOL
VIEWPOINT ON THEO THE CLASSROOM.
WE ARE PROSS WITGREES IN
>> AND SHE IS ALSO THE MOM OF A
>> SO, I SORRY.N YOU ASME
>> RepE TALK ETTING PISSED OFF
WHY DO IKE YOU
STUFF?O I GEWH OHO DON'T HAVE
PLACE ANN  IR
THE SAKE OF PERSEC
ON THEIR
>> WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING THIS
CURRICULUM EVERYWHERE, AND
YOU'RE TELLINGS HEY, CAN
COME TO TALK TO ME BEHD
PANT YOUBACK.
I MEAN, THERE IS CLEAR
SCHOOLS.RE OF THAT INTO OUR
AND IT'S JUST NOT TH
PL
>> SO WHAT I FEEL LIKE'RE
STRONGLY IMPLYING, AND I WOULD
LIKE TO GEE ON,
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
ATTRIBUTMEO ME IT SOUNDSIKE
YOAYG KIND
OF HIGH-LEVEL COORDINATED EFFORP
>> Reporter: WELL, WHO I?
>> TEACHERIONS AND OUR
ENT AND A LOT  FUNDING
SOURCES, AND TEACHERRE
ALSO HEAVILY BACKI
CURRICT WE'RE BR
>> Reporter: WHY WOUHEY WANT
MORE KTO BE GA>> BECAUSE IT BRE
FA DOWN
TRADNAUES.
IT BREAKS DOWN A LOT  COUNTRY.
IT THAT PEOPLEK.
IT CHANGES THE WAYHA
POLI
>> Reporter: OF COURSE THERE IV
KIDS TRANS.
R THOSE THOUGHTS ABO OF NCO MA
IT SOUND LIKE
THEORY TO YO
>> IT'S NOT A CONSPIRACYHEY
THAT THIS STATE,HE
TALKING ABOUT COLORADO OR THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION, IN RAISING OUR
KIDSK THAT FREASON PEOPLE WANT
WHAT I THINK.
E WILL USE- WANT T RIGHTS, THE
LAST OF TEACHERS UNIONS, THEY'LL
USQ OR WHATEVEY BE THE
CASET THE TIME.
OOLS TO ERODE
AWAY AT PRAENL
>> Reporter: THE LAST MEETING
WAS MOSTLY ABOUT STUDENT AWARDS
AND PETHE BOARO ANTIFE FOR LIBET
NG ROGUE WTEACHERS, WOKE TEAER T
>> Rte A COUPLE OF ENTS PUSH BA
>> IF YOU REMOVE TEACHERS'
Y  AOU  REMOVE THR
>> THE STUDENTS ANSUPPORT
STAFF THATG OUR
UDENTS OUT THERE
>> MY CHILD THINKS IT'
LUDICROUS THAT IT'CH
THEM IT'S JUST , THEY D HOW MYI
THHE
IS I TO YOU
WHICH SIDE DEBATE HATHE MOUP IN
THAT SCHOODISTRICT, FOR CE?
R GONEO PUBLICAIT A MINUTE, HER'
GO SCHOOL? THEY HAVEER B
SHS MAE BY HIGH SCHOOL
THE SCHOOLS WILL ENOUGH
FOR HER KIDS.
DS WE TALK TO, THEL DSTHT THE MY
N.
ONE PARENTNED ABOU
WERE OBSCENEMMITTEES TO ETHER